Welcome back everyone marvel just started loki
season 2 released a first look with a bunch of
cool easter eggs and connections to what just
happened in doctor strange 2 with the incursions
time runs out the secret wars teaser which they're
combining with the new kang multiverse war which
is obviously loki season 2 so we'll break it all
down and from that as kang begins to wear his head
and do his deeds in so many ways he has no choice
but to be in opposition or to be different from
he who remains i can't wait to see how loki
and sylvia are going to mess up the multiverse
this time it'll be spectacular if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos of course i'll be doing full episode videos
just like i did for season one i'm also announcing
the winners from my special bespoke post video
during this so look out for that but the first
look of the scenes from loki season 2 just came
from the cinematographer who released a picture
on his instagram of our main loki variant in a
scene mirroring the early part of loki season 1.
i actually had to snag it from another website who
grabbed it just as he deleted his post apparently
because when i went to his instagram all his posts
had been deleted so hopefully the marvel snipers
didn't get to him but we still got a look at that
scene and as you can see it's loki dressed in
the standard tva prison garb again in the same
color that you saw him in at the beginning of
loki episode 1 when they first captured him it's
meant to be a big joke and reference everything
that he who remains king was talking about
at the end of season 1 when sylvie killed him
like haha here we go again history repeats itself
because literally this is a time travel series so
events often seemingly repeat themselves by design
you're jumping all over the timeline or in special
cases they even have special time travel devices
which trap people in specific time loops meant to
torture them very effective torture device but the
reason why he's back in prison garb is because of
course they would arrest him because they think
he's a variant they don't know anything about
him they've never seen him before this version
of mobius and this version of hunter b-15 from
the new kang's timeline who's made his timeline
supreme wouldn't have known him wouldn't know
anything about the events of season one with our
loki having to spend the beginning of the episode
in some hilarious montage trying to convince
them that everything he was shouting about he
who remains in the truth of the tva was actually
true it's all a lie you're all variants there's a
person controlling all of it the big difference
between he who remains in this version of kang
though is that this version is way more comic book
accurate but also there's a statue of him there's
no time masters he's not hiding behind anybody
so it's going to be that much harder for him
to convince the tva to get rid of him he probably
hasn't been lying to them the same way that he who
remains king was lying to this version of the tva
but you can imagine that funny quick montage of
moments just like the beginning of season one with
him going through the rigmarole of having to spout
about the actual truth like he was shouting at
the beginning of season one saying why don't you
arrest the avengers they time traveled all over
the place and obviously the new timeline that he
comes back to is different because now a version
of king the conqueror from the comics is ruling
over this version or at least he's in the middle
of winning this verse of the king multiverse war
but that's basically what's happening when he runs
back into the tva and learns that everything's
different they're in the middle of a war that's
why there are so many incursions so many nexus
events happening all at once and everything seems
like utter chaos if you didn't see it too you also
hear casey in the background who in this timeline
is now a hunter and seems like a certified badass
like he's part of a squad going to run to stop an
incursion this time so i believe at the beginning
of the season only our version of loki sylvie and
potentially the ren slayer who also escaped at the
end of last season will remember what happened
during the original timeline and based on the
release schedule it sounds like it will take place
after the events of ant-man through quantomania
because now that's coming out in february and this
probably isn't going to come out till next summer
it is possible that the version of kang that we
see on loki season 2 is different from the version
that we see in ant-man 3 quantum mania but because
of the way time travel works you can actually kill
kang during ant-man 3 and then later you can still
see him during loki season 2 with it making sense
the big connection between kang and ant-man
is that all the kang variants and the tva
consequently use quantum energy to power
their time travel portal technology like
this is quantum energy the same way that the
avengers did an endgame using all that pymtech
and pym's research into the quantum realm so if it
wasn't clear there's one quantum realm connecting
the entire multiverse so of course any variant
of kang would be spending time in the quantum
realm or using quantum energy in some way we also
learned in doctor strange 2 that reed richards the
fantastic four on the illuminati's universe used
quantum energy to make similar types of portals
just not quite as advanced as kang's tech reed
richards is also a distant relative of kang the
conqueror so there might be a connection to kang
in the new fantastic four movie two the cool thing
with kang is also the kevin feige and jonathan
magers have revealed that we'll see many different
versions of kang in future movies in disney plus
series so hydra style kill one in a billion kangs
rise up in his place and also because marvel is
saying that the incursions time runs out and the
kang multiverse war are basically all kind of the
same thing it seems like kang or one of the kangs
is going to be the central figure in the secret
wars battle world style movie eventually whatever
that avengers movie winds up being avengers 5 or
avengers 6. in the comics that was god emperor
doom and involved a big war that they fought
against the beyonders it sounds like in the mcu
version of events it'll be the kang multiverse war
with a version of kang winning and creating battle
world where they all punch it out and figure
out how to try and restore the multiverse but
the beauty of them using a bunch of different kang
variants and different types of projects is that
they can kill all them off in hilarious or really
epic wtf ways and still have the actor come back
and play other even worse versions tom hiddleston
said that the entire main cast is returning some
people heard him say that the entire cast was
returning and thought that meant that all the loki
variants were coming back to i think that some of
them will be back but not all the loki variants
like classic loki for example he was awesome but
he died this epic death i don't think they want
to trample on that so i'm not expecting him to
come back but like alligator loki supreme loki
and kid loki were really awesome hopefully they'll
come back and obviously we'll probably see a bunch
of brand new loki variants show up too that we
haven't seen before maybe frog thor will also
come back too that would be really cool in the
finale sylvie took he who remains time travel
wrist device and took off she still got that with
her but eventually she and the main loki will find
each other again and find a way to stop this new
king who's made his own timeline the supreme one
while also somehow making the problem of all
the incursions and time runs out secret wars
even worse that's the beauty of the characters
like they do save the day but they wind up pouring
gasoline on the flame and things get even worse
somehow it makes for great teasers for future
movies the worse things get the more entertaining
they get the big difference between season one and
season two though is that season one was all
about them discovering the existence of he who
remains king and learning the truth of the tva
that he'd been using variants over time wiping
their minds along the way they start season two
already knowing that in taboo this version of kang
isn't even hiding like he's very honest about who
he is and how he's controlling this version of the
timeline gugu and bottom raw said that her version
of ren slayer that escape would be going way
darker during season two but they might have some
variance of her because if we're in a new timeline
then a new version of renslayer would probably be
running the tva but it could either be the old ren
slayer just pretending to be a new ren slayer
or it could legitimately be a new variant and
because this version of kang the conqueror ruling
over this version of the timeline the tba seems
much more present we might see more easter eggs
for their relationship in the comics too because
renslayer was basically the love interest for kang
the conqueror they kind of alluded to that during
season 1 like she was getting secret messages from
he her remains but it didn't seem like they had a
full-blown relationship she only knew that there
was a mysterious figure telling her what to do
giving her instructions but remember the message
is the end of season one he remains saying you
think that i'm bad wait till you meet the others
even if loki and sylvie stop this new version of
kang there are so many other ones out there that
are way more evil threatening to take over so
season 2 probably going to end with a similar type
of wtf cliffhanger where they solve one problem
but somehow wind up making things way worse and
just to explain how incursions are similar to the
kang multiverse war basically incursions are when
different universes collide with each other or
overlap destroying one or both of them or part of
them when that happens it's like dominoes there's
a cascade effect more and more collide with each
other it happens faster and faster until you're
left with no more universes that's literally
why the storyline is called time runs out in
the comics and during doctor strange 2 they were
saying that incursions can happen for multiple
reasons reed richards of the fantastic four blames
doctor strange and scarlet witch for causing
one to happen because they weaken the barrier
between dimensions destabilizing the multiverse
the kang multiverse war is basically different
variants of kang causing incursions on purpose
with the intent that they destroy everyone else's
universe but their own is like kang's going around
pouring gasoline on a match burning down the
entire multiverse just in terms of surprise cameos
from big actors there were a lot of big surprises
during season one i would expect similar treatment
some special cameos during season two as well they
also said episodes of what if season two are going
to air later this year in 2022 and then a lot of
that plot pulled from what happened during marvel
phase four including the loki's series so we might
see some connection between loki season 2 and what
if season 2. but if you have any questions about
loki season 2 or any secret war stuff post them in
the comments and i'll do more videos when we get
more footage and easter eggs like i said season 2
probably gonna come out around this time next year
they'll have six episodes just like season one
my obi-wan kenobi episode 5 video will post next
after they release it in my miss marvel episode
2 video after that links for all my loki videos
down in the description below too congratulations
servo driven xavier ramirez in ragin at games you
guys are the winners of those special bespoke post
boxes please email me on the about page of my
channel or on my website emergencyawesome.com so i
can get your contact info everyone click here for
my brand new spider-man across the spider-verse
trailer and first look video and click here for
my brand new thor love and thunder trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!